do either of you have any type of mantra
or something that you tell yourself in
terms of once you do audition in letting
it go and not obsessing and checking the
phone or is that just part of your
process I physically throw away my
materials in the office when I'm done
Thank You firemen and hopefully there's
a trash can in the room as I'm walking
out so they can see me putting it down
like I look you either you're either in
it or you're not you know what I mean
you either want me or you don't
so I'm not you know I try not to think
about it any more than that I mean
you'll Drive you know you audition
hundreds of times a year and if you put
stock into all of that
I mean you get a few of them and yeah so
the numbers aren't that great yeah so
you're gonna be in a pretty bad place I
think a lot of the time if you don't you
know what I mean you got to just look at
it as your time you know this is my
chance to act today in a sort of
controlled setting you know what I mean
I'm gonna go in here and just do
something for a few minutes and it's a
moment to go play and then don't see it
any more than that yeah I think that
like leaving the audition behind isn't
as hard for me as like sometimes if it's
something I've been preparing for for
awhile if it's like oh regardless of
whether or not it's a role you that I
really want I think in order to go in
and like serve the character or whatever
it is you have to you you have to do all
the work behind it obviously and I think
that the like letting go of that it
feels like it's like a death of like
somebody that you got to know sometimes
if you got really attached to the person
that you were playing or like if you're
really connected with that or especially
if it was something where you had to go
somewhere difficult emotionally I think
that that is harder for me to leave
behind is like not so much all I wanted
that so bad it was just like the chance
to play something that
maybe you were more connected to or or
that felt more real to you and that's
the kind of stuff that I'll think about
later I make Hajj I wish I hope I get
the chance to or whatever you know so
but um as far as like the audition yeah
if you if you beat yourself up about
should have done this or why did I say
that why did I wear this or whatever
like yeah you just be beating yourself
up all the time and then that doesn't
bode well for any time you walk in a
room that reads on you I think well I
think there's a very fine line like when
you're in a room with a director
there's a very fine line of wanting to
please and staying true to you know
taking the direction but staying true to
what it is you need to do because that
that need to please can take over and
take you to a place that you shouldn't
be going when you're not really you're
just you know anyway I felt that when I
first started in the business it was
like I would be so caught up in just
wanting to please them and giving them
what they want that I was losing a
handle on everything that was me and
everything that was the only thing that
was going to separate me from the other
knuckleheads that walked in the door
before me and after me you know what I
mean it's like so you've got to find
that balance of of course I want to give
the director what he wants that's my job
that's my only job is to service the
author's words within the picture of
this director but at the same time you
can't get so lost in that moment of that
audition space of just being like I
gotta do this I gotta do that I got to
get this job it's like the second that
takes so long I mean you might as well
forget it you know it's over at that
point
you